we met in DC when you were a member and
uh I liked you immediately because we
were at a campaign Finance reform event
and you said hey DC is even worse than I
thought I'm the only member who doesn't
dial for dollars I thought I was kind of
here to legislate and do something good
and uh and I heard this and I said wow
uh like more of America should hear
about this guy uh and and then you made
headlines where you said what you
actually thought which was was hey uh
maybe candidates other than Joe Biden
should consider running um not because
Joe Biden is not a good person um but he
may not be the best candidate um to
field and then you got a tremendous
amount of blowback from that at least
that was the sense I I got from the
outside looking in that's a fair that's
a fair that's a good sense you got and
I'd imagine that that must have been
sort of bewildering for you because
people were saying the exact same thing
as you were saying in private they were
thinking the same thing and then you
said something that in my mind was
fairly conventional wisdom and all of a
sudden it was like this headline making
oh like Dean is um somehow sticking a a
black eye on the party or something
and was was that the um was that the
experience from your side well first of
all you know Andrew let me let me
compliment you you know when over the
last year as we've gotten to know each
other you know I had some perspective
from the inside of Congress and the
inside of Washington and you had had
this experience running for president
from the outside and I'm discovering uh
what you did last time around and I
shared with you what I discovered from
the inside you know both have
significant deficiencies that need to be
addressed and I'll tell you the disease
that is afflicting both is a disease of
Silence uh and a disease of fear uh and
a lack of courage and what you just said
is people say one thing privately and
they say something totally toally
different publicly which is why I think
only 10% of Americans have significant
faith in their Congress and it makes
perfect sense so that's the disease I
used to think it was only a disease of
the right uh when Donald Trump was
President my Republican colleagues would
say the same thing every day quietly
he's appalling he's dangerous uh his
character is is horrifying and then they
get in front of the cameras and lights
and say that he was the greatest thing
since sliced bread and then I started
hearing the same stuff on my side people
having conversations about President
Biden's deficiencies uh the decline the
numbers the fear that he's going to lose
uh and now almost the certainty that
he's going to lose and yet when they get
in front of cameras and in public say
something totally different and I think
that is the most dangerous a front to
democracy when people in elected
positions trying to represent people
ostensibly say something different than
they feel and I'll tell you when 70 some
percent of the country wants neither Joe
Biden nor Donald Trump to be the next
president and only one member of
Congress out of 535 really stood up and
said it which is me we got problems and
I torpedoed my career but my goodness I
do it a thousand times over because this
is a big deal it's existential yeah from
from my vantage point Dean uh it is
madness to run uh an 81-year-old
unpopular incumbent with a 37% approval
rating who is down in the swing States
represents the status quo
easily the oldest uh president in
history uh against someone like Donald
Trump who would be a catastrophe uh in
office his second term would make his
first term look like sanity Central in
my opinion his second term would be
cataclysmic and you know who I have a
bone to pick with and I don't know if
you feel this way but I'll say it um I I
have a real problem now with Gavin Nome
JB pritzker Gretchen Whitmer these other
folks who clear clearly are gearing up
for a run for the White House but are
lying in waight uh for 2028 I mean what
the hell's going to be left for us in
2028 if Trump wins in 2024 I feel like
people like that are putting their own
professional interest ahead of the
countries and it makes me think of them
as frankly unpresidential um and and
that's something that I
feel I mean for you to say that might be
a little bit harsh and rough but like I
I want to put that idea out there do you
have any response to that yeah that was
my message Andrew that you can't wait
till 2028 because we probably will not
have one at least an election that we've
come to know and that's exactly my point
you know you got to run to the fire when
your country is burning not away from it
and I'm disappointed I I think they're
good people that's why I called them I
think they should have and could have
joined the stage and offered their names
but I have to tell you the one my one
defense of them
is I think they knew better than I how
this machine turns on anybody you know
what I mean I mean it and I want to be
forthright I think they know I think
that's why Gavin Newsome is doing
everything but getting on the ballot
because he knows what happens if you
would so much as raise your voice and
have the audacity to enter your name on
a Democratic primary ballot when the
country needs you he knows what the
machine will do and they're doing it to
me and I was not prepared for it I did
not expect uh the weight uh the
antagonism uh and frankly the delusion
the delusion of a party that really
should be focusing on debate on
competition and participation and
instead of promoting those three things
they are literally working against it I
do think those candidates understand how
this works my only disappointment is
that they're not participating in fixing
it and the best way to fix it would be
to join the race not just one not just
two let's have three four five of us
doing what you do in democracy look at
the Republican ticket Donald Trump is 50
60 points ahead of everybody that was on
stage there last night right that's not
stopping them from doing it not stopping
them and he's not showing up to debate
either Biden's not showing up to debate
I think we have a real crisis and I'm
I'm disappointed I think they should
have and could have and if they're
waiting till 2028 like you said I think
that shows uh a deficiency when a
country really really needs someone uh
and that's exactly I am subjecting
myself to this and I've torpedoed my
career in Congress and that's okay
because I was not willing to see the
country torpedoed by Donald Trump indeed
man I mean when when I decided to run in
the last cycle I said to myself you know
what uh no matter what I'm going to be a
to look in at myself in the mirror and
say I did everything I could like I'll
be able to sleep at night you know I
mean like that's the most important test
and you should be sleeping soundly
because you're definitely putting it all
I'll sleep I'll sleep soundly I'll sleep
soundly the day after the election next
November hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you